my name is Seth manikin I'm the director
of the communications forum before we
start there are a couple of quick
announcements first we'd like to thank
both the de Flores fund for humor and
the MIT political science department for
helping to put on tonight's event there
is in addition to this this forum
tonight there's going to be a screening
of the entire documentary tickling
Giants tomorrow at 7 p.m. in 26100 and
that is also free and open to the public
I think is that information also on our
site yes so if you did not write that
down you can also go to the
communications forum site we have a
mailing list and a pen right up here so
if you are interested in this type of
thing please sign up we will only send
you six emails a year to announce each
of the six events that we will have we
don't give out your email to anyone else
but if you would like to stay informed
about things we are doing please do sign
up after I introduce the speakers we are
actually going to show a trailer for the
film itself and then we will start the
event and our next communications forum
after tonight is on Thursday November
8th and that is with Eric Lander the
director of the Broad Institute and
Maria Zuber mi t--'s head of research
and they will be discussing whether
America is losing its miracle machine
whether we need to have Rome more robust
funding for basic research and what we
are in danger of losing when we don't do
that so with that out of the way I'd
like to introduce our our guests for
tonight to my left your right amber day
is a professor of media and performance
studies at Bryant University she's the
author of satire and dissent
interventions in contemporary
debate and the editor of DIY utopia
cultural imagination and the remaking of
the possible her work focuses on the
intersections of art and political
speech including satire and irony
political performance and activism and
public debate she also has a background
in performance and improv comedy which
we will not make you do improv later
tonight right still you know Sarah Tex
ler has worked for for late-night shows
including 12 years at The Daily Show
where she was senior producer her
documentary tickling Giants premiered at
the Tribeca Film Festival and the New
York giant the New York Times called it
a first-rate documentary variety called
it an ebullient ode to freedom a
graduate of Washington University in st.
Louis she can talk backwards Wow and you
were not on Twin Peaks it seems like
that's something that would be very
useful for that how did you learn how to
talk backwards I'd like to say I was a
young child when I realized I could do
it but I was in college and Friends and
tried to read something and realized it
was easy for me and it totally freaked
me out super cool kind of obsessed with
Twin Peaks
it's yeah seriously it's a good thing
I'm not moderating oh it would be tax
alert can talk backwards yes and has a
remarkable fake sneeze as well so will
now show the the trailer and then like
all forums we'll start out with a
moderated discussion with our guests and
then we will open it up to audience Q&A
so thank you all so much
oh and during the audience Q&A if you
could come to one of the mics and if you
don't mind identifying yourself just
because we do include a synopsis of the
event and all the questions and then we
don't need to just call you a person but
can let everyone know who you are all
right thank you so much
you
[Applause]
ho testers on the streets in Cairo Egypt
island clashes are raging once again
flashes between protesters and security
forces more than 1200 people have died
hey boss some Yousef is known as Egypt's
Jon Stewart 30 million viewers for his
weekly program 40 percent of the entire
population is watching someone who's
saying things that are similar to what
we're saying to each other things that
are not usually on TV I think it's very
brave of him
[Music]
Egypt's public prosecutor is all of the
rest of popular television presented by
some uses were saying that he has
insulted President Mohammed Morsi and
insulted Islam that a comedian would be
a wanted man is itself an astonishing
thing the satire gets you into trouble
I'll tell you this it doesn't get me the
kind of trouble that gets you into and
up to the beste musik later
[Applause]
it could be safer I have absolutely no
manual to do this revolution is going to
throw a very critical moment we've been
waiting for something to happen
hopefully lives in a fee a cover time
this show is about holding Authority
accountable regardless of who's in
charge screw them
we are the voice on the people
[Applause]
[Music]
so funny and you all should watch it if
you haven't seen it it's great it is
really a great film
so yeah let's start from the beginning
I'm I'm assuming that you met bassem
youssef first when working at the Daily
Show and I'm wondering what made you
what made you want to follow him and
actually embark on this project that was
totally different from what you were
doing at the time well first I'd like to
acknowledge that it's funny to be two
feet from someone I hear their voice so
loud and these microphones it's a very
interesting experience
I am I and also I just wanna say thanks
to MIT and Kristen sethen and you amber
for having me I met Boston at the Daily
Show and he came in to observe and I was
just talking to someone about this right
before in the audience we had never had
anyone do that before come in just for
the purpose of observing us and he came
with three producers and the room that I
sat in happened to be kind of a spacious
spot and right across from my desk there
were some couches so they just hung out
in there during the day and we got to
talk a bunch and there were a few things
one is he was a heart surgeon at the
time I couldn't imagine John Stewart
doing heart surgery during the day and
then hosting the daily show at night not
say he couldn't it's just hard to
picture also I had had an idea that I'm
still interested in about following a
late-night show for the year leading up
to an election I was a fan of the movie
the war room and I liked the fact that
they followed a presidential campaign
but the most famous person in that room
was like a tiny part of the story and it
was really about the process and the
staff and I thought there was something
interesting about how a satire show
deals with difficult moments and I had
kind of plotted out what that might look
like and then when I met possum I
thought this is that story with much
much higher stakes
and then the other thing is there were
four of them including bossman came two
of them were women and I was really
curious what it would be like to be my
counterpart as a woman working as a
producer at a comedy show in Egypt and I
was just curious and impulsively asked
blossom if I could make a movie about
him and he said yes and I think both of
us were then like what did we just agree
to do and and sat on it for a little bit
until we figured out how to actually
make it happen right and then how long
were you actually in Egypt filming like
what's the time period that's covered so
I met possum in 2012 but when he was at
the Daily Show which you'll see in the
movie tomorrow he there's footage of it
he was being followed around by his
producers who were like taping every
single thing he did so I figured there
was a good chance there was other
footage right so between their footage
and other archival that we got the story
begins in 2011 and then we filmed from
until 2014 in Egypt and then some here
including some right in Cambridge later
in the film and I wasn't basically the
way late-night shows work for the most
part you have about ten weeks off a year
like these unpaid dark weeks so the
whole show shuts down you have two
working dark weeks where everyone's in
the office but for the rest you can kind
of do what you want so I would use those
to work in the film and then a few times
I went to Egypt where I had to take off
work but just because there were things
that I couldn't schedule like the show
was coming back and a new network or
things like that that were
time-sensitive
mm-hmm-hmm and I think there's this
funny irony in that of course all the
marketing materials for the film he's
described as Egypt's Jon Stewart which
totally makes sense for an American
audience to sort of understand who he is
and yet my understanding is that when he
was at the height of his popularity he
his audience was much larger than Jon
Stewart is on a given night unlike
anything we've ever had here pot maybe
Johnny Carson
and in his heyday but they would get
between 30 and 40 million viewers per
episode Jon Stewart was getting 2
million per episode so there's literally
nothing I can compare it to you I guess
like the closest thing would be the
Superbowl but it was every week and it
he was doing something people didn't
hadn't seen before like there's satire
in Egypt that was making fun of weather
and traffic and more benign things but
not political humor ever and certainly
not the expense for the president so
some people were tuning in because they
loved watching and some people were
tuning in because they hated him but
[Music]
exactly but I'm sure he didn't mind the
comparison no I mean in fact I think he
started it I think I love John Stewart
and he wanted to meet John Stewart so he
was contacting everyone he knew trying
to find a way to get to the Daily Show
and we kind of condensed it in the movie
but when he comes to New York it wasn't
to be on The Daily Show originally it
was to observe and then he kind of like
charmed everyone including John and they
asked if you'd like to come on as a
guest so that was like his personal goal
because he was a fan but it's not
certainly wasn't something that most
people who need to watch the people who
worked on the show knew it and there's
one cable channel that would carry daily
show and at the time Colbert
so unless you happen to have that
channel you wouldn't know it and ferb
awesome he kind of had to train himself
to watch because aside from I guess at
the time I know who I guess Obama was in
office
aside from Obama he didn't know most of
the politicians so you kind of have to
do research to understand satire to the
game most people in Egypt wouldn't know
the players and then as you as we saw in
the in the trailer even Jon Stewart
makes a visit to his set as well and
it's a big surprise were you
instrumental in setting that up in that
visit actually Jon so bossom really
wanted John to visit and John made a
movie called rose water that was filming
in Jordan and he took the summer off to
and before he left Boston came on again
and John told him one in the Middle East
I'll come see you guys so they had
already put that into motion themselves
and then coincidentally the one of the
producers on this film is Maziar Bahari
who was the star of rose well he wasn't
the actor II this tour was based on his
life but it was funny because neither of
us had ever met and when bossom
suggested to us that we worked together
we both kind of said to John like is
this a good idea and he's like yeah that
would be a good match right very cool
and so by the time you started filming
in Egypt obviously you had quite a bit
of experience at the Daily Show and what
was it like coming from I mean The Daily
Show is high-profile and it has a
relatively high budget because Edison
American show on Comedy Central how did
it compare to what what the Egyptian
show look like in backstage I mean big
picture very similar detail wise very
different so like when I got there it
was like the bizarro episode of Seinfeld
where everyone kind of looked and acted
like the people I worked with at home
but they were like Achmed instead of
Adams and so in some ways it was like a
weird I felt like I've been here before
even though it was all brand new I'm an
atmosphere wise it's self-selected like
people who want to work on a satire show
are interested in current events and are
passionate about politics and like to
make jokes about things so in that way I
was similar there were a lot of
differences in terms of like the makeup
of the staff because it hadn't been done
before so there were a few people who
had TV backgrounds but the vast majority
were engineers and architects and
lawyers and people have fresh out of
college who just opposite seem cool and
they were fans of possums YouTube show
so when he got a TV show they were like
I would like to do this that that's not
really
typically a TV show here and then there
were a lot of it was much harder for
that
just in terms of things available I mean
these types of shows have been around
for a while so there's lots of services
that kind of cater to us I mean there's
the AP has transcription services and
Nexus has transcriptions which make our
lives easier and finding clips and we
use most TV shows now or many at least
use this program called snap stream
which is like a DVR just for the
channels you set up
that's searchable and you can play clips
so like we would record every news
channel
every big speech all the c-span's all
day long and then when we would need to
find a mighty speaker series you type it
in and anytime anyone has said it since
you've been recording it shows up and
that was something that was developed
during the course of me being at the
daily show it was harder at the
beginning but they had nothing like that
it was literally people watching every
show transcribing every word suggesting
clips and then showing those clips so
they just had a lot more work to do you
know and where many of them still
working at their regular job yeah
everyone was full time there were
interns who some of whom were still in
school but the staff were all full-time
very much full-time like long days and
obviously and as we can tell from the
trailer as well that there's some fear
that builds and and and bossom and his
staff are in fear for their lives really
how did you feel mad did you feel like
you were in danger and your crew was in
danger when you were there well so that
was something that was a surprise I mean
for everyone
I certainly when I asked awesome if I
could make the movie I thought it was
like a delightful romp through this
person coming out of the Arab Spring to
do this comedy show but he becomes a
lightning rod and to this day still is
like I will walk down the street with
him and they'll be people who love Him
and to show their affection they'll be
like you know can I buy you a water
bottle or just anything to say hello and
thank you and then there's other people
who scream at him that he's a traitor
walking him and Hatton you know so he
still is mostly loved but very divisive
excuse me but in Egypt yeah there were a
bunch of things that were challenging
one I mean I didn't have a budget while
filming so I went by myself and hired a
local crew so in terms of shooting
low-budget solo some of the challenges
were we had it wasn't as commonplace at
least a few years ago for people to film
things or take pictures the way and we
probably couldn't go anywhere today and
not see someone taking a selfie or
something that was not the culture so
anything with a camera was a problem
potentially so we had a camera person
who was beaten up and his footage was
taken and they kept asking whose side he
was on and they meant politically and he
was trying to explain he was just making
a movie about a TV show and that was
another sufficient answer so we tried to
not get any publicity and not say
anything on social media about filming
until we were done with the Egypt
portion of the filming there was one
time when possum goes to a new network
and there's major protests outside and
there's a scene in the film where they
offered that people don't have to come
to work the next day because they know
they're going to be these protests and
they were afraid the office was gonna
get fire bombs and I was kind of like
how they don't come in because then I
don't have to go but unfortunately but
really fortunately they were very brave
and and went and I was filming outside
with one of our camera people and they
asked me to go inside because they were
concerned that I'm clearly not Egyptian
and they thought that I might spark some
trouble because there were rumors that
possum was a CIA operative and they
thought that I would add legitimacy to
that so when I went outside people
started screaming and they asked if I
would go inside and I was trying to film
like the second camera and I just had to
stop shooting because my hand was
shaking and then a different time when
there was going to be protests one of
bosen's publicist told me she didn't
think I should
because she was afraid that if there was
a problem she didn't want to feel
responsible so I talked to bossom and he
was like I think you should come because
I'm gonna be there and worst case
scenario you get blown up and if you do
then a Daily Show producer got blown up
at my show and that's great publicity he
was all for it and luckily that didn't
happen but on that trip 60 minutes was
shooting that week also a profile and I
kind of realized how ill-equipped I was
in some ways by seeing the team they had
versus ready detail charity detail and
they they had someone whose full-time
job was just providing them with plans
on escape routes essentially and on the
day of the taping there was a lot of
protests and there were like the
equivalent of SWAT teams all over the
place and two of the guys were
whispering to each other and it kind of
pointed to me and they called me over
and said if something happens in the
back there's an alley and there's a
ladder and if you climb over the ladder
there's a van and you can jump in and
come with us and I said well what's
gonna happen and they said if it happens
you'll know and I was like okay thank
you and it just made me realize that I
didn't have a good plan B if you know
but at the same time for the most part
it's a big city and even when something
bad happens in one place it's not like
everything shuts down I mean the same as
it is here and things were mostly okay
there were I mean a few other things
like that but one was the hotel I say
that a few times was a Marriott and I
found out the second time I stayed there
it was known as the Marriott cell and
before I knew this I noticed that I had
only stayed there one other time and
granted tourism was very low so there
weren't a lot of people staying there
but I noticed when I walked in that
everyone who worked there recognized me
and I'm a woman traveling alone and my
skin was lighter and there were reasons
maybe I stand out but I was just like
blown away by the customers
that they knew who I was and then I
heard this story and so al Jazeera
journalists were staying at this hotel
and were arrested and there were
concerns that maybe the staff had turned
them in or something happen and then it
just makes you paranoid like whether or
not there's truth to it I was afraid to
write my journal when I stayed there or
talked to my family because you're just
not sure and one night I was eating
dinner at the hotel restaurant and just
doing some work and this guy was just
staring at me and I paid my bill and
left and I was afraid to go into my room
so I went to the lobby of the hotel and
he was behind me and I went to a sitting
area he was behind me and there was a
business center and he was behind me
and my phone rang and it was Boston just
checking in saying hi and he asked how I
was and I said actually I'm freaked out
I'm freaking out I'm nervous right now
and I told him what was going on and he
was like oh don't worry he wants you
baby I was like what and he was like oh
he's flirting with you
and I said I don't think so and I
thought it was a case of just a guy not
quite getting it and the next morning I
told some women in the office what was
going on they're like oh yeah he was
flirting with you and I it's just a
different social norm and I was used to
and it was kind of an example of just as
a woman traveling alone something I can
write freak you out even if it I
probably was not actually in danger in
that moment but yeah and and did the
films
so you said you kept a low profile as
which is probably better for them that
it didn't draw attention to to them and
get them in trouble did this film then
screen in Egypt after you'd finished it
it has screened once publicly well so
outside North America it's on Netflix so
a few years ago Egypt got Netflix so we
weren't sure what was going to happen
when it came out and then kind of to the
last minute we didn't know if they were
gonna let it play and and they did so it
is people in their homes can view it
we had one public screening which was at
a university in Cairo and they planned
the whole screening and
we set up a Skype Q&A with blossom and
everyone was excited and the day before
they told bossom that they were told
that they weren't allowed to do it but
that he had to announce he was canceling
because they couldn't announce that we
weren't letting him doing that the
government wouldn't allow it
and so the agreement was that they would
do the screening but not they the school
will be allowed to do the screening but
only if he didn't do the Q&A so we they
did the screening and there was it was a
700 seat place but filled up and
apparently it went really well but
unfortunately he couldn't be a part of
it and I imagine obviously when you
started the film you had no idea how it
was gonna end up or how what how it was
gonna end but did you I mean did you
have a sense of what was gonna happen
with the show and whether it was gonna
be controversial or did it sort of go in
a direction no when it started I thought
it was more I mean the story that
interested me was this idea which is
explained in the film but tickling
giants the term is about it comes out of
this little cartoon which is the thing
on my shirt but there's a guy who works
at the show who's a writer
draws this cartoon of a little guy who's
bossom with a feather tickling a giant
and I like that picture and the term
tickling giants came out and kind of
what it came to mean was an individual
finding a creative nonviolent way to
draw attention to an abuse of power so I
thought this story was about the fact
that bossom was a regular guy who his
country fell into this revolution and
things got extremely violent and through
his nonviolent means he he got so much
more attention than the people who were
literally a mile away from his office
killing each other and that was really
interesting to me that using humor he
had such
your microphone and a much stronger
impact on people and dialogue and so the
thing I was into initially and and still
is that my big takeaway for the film
it's the idea that anyone can have that
most of us aren't going to start a
comedy show and become one of the most
famous comedians in the world probably
but but everyone has a thing that they
could do and that was what was
interesting was that he was a private
citizen and not a celebrity and he had
this huge impact I definitely didn't
think it was his life would would become
as difficult as it did right and on that
note do you are there any updates about
what he's doing now and yeah he I saw
him two or three days ago he lives in
Los Angeles and he likes his joke is
that he's taking meetings which he says
his LA speak for like not really doing
anything but he would like to be a
performer writer in film and TV and and
the ideal thing would be to get a
special like Netflix or HBO and then get
a show out of it like he'd like to do a
show focusing on international issues
and free speech issues but it's hard
he's remaking his life in another
country and as exceptionally famous as
he is most people here have never heard
of him right so he kind of has to
reinvent himself again but he's enjoying
the stuff he's doing he tours with the
movie sometimes he's doing a show online
about he's vegan and very committed to
plant-based diets so he's doing some
stuff about that and right now he's in
New York from this weekend next week at
a venue called Joe's Pub which is a
great theater in New York City doing a
one-man show and when I went the other
night when we walked out of the show we
saw Lymon while Miranda standing a
lobbyist who's very excited so
particularly Janice the musical is
hopefully the next step so obviously his
show was shut down in Egypt is he does
he feel free to travel back to Egypt or
does no absolutely he has not been back
not to ruin the movie but there's legal
issues which is why he left and he just
doesn't know what would happen if he
walked in I mean it could be immediate
arrest he doesn't know what would happen
so unfortunately he hasn't been back
he's seen family when you know out of
the country but he hasn't been able to
go to anything right that's hard it's
very hard and what do you think of his
legacy in Egypt I mean since that part
of his life is over right and his he's
remaking his life here but so what do
you think his legacy is in that country
well so something we thought about a lot
in the Edit was whether he has a legacy
of hope or not that he left and
basically the discussion was around the
fact that we had a bunch of Egyptians on
our team and a few people felt like you
don't want it to seem too hopeful
because then people leave the movie and
think all right it's done I don't have
to care I don't have to do anything but
you also don't want it to feel
completely devastating because then why
bother trying and I think it's somewhere
in the middle I think I mean his show
being canceled it was devastating but I
think a little bit more so for the
people who made the show in the audience
then for him for him making it was
devastating his life was completely
turned upside down and you know
unlivable and so I think for him there
was a drop of relief even though leaving
the country certainly was not relief but
not having to be that much of a
lightning rod I think it was probably a
nice thing but so I think for his legacy
in my mind it's the idea that this can
happen right now it's definitely not and
there are common there's a Saturday
Night Live spin-off there and they make
jokes about weather and traffic and
other family issues and you know a
little easier to joke about things but
no one is doing political satire I think
it's kind of hard to say
whether it will happen again but my
feeling is once people have experienced
free speech
they'll want it again and I think we see
in our own country a lot of people are
willing to trade free speech if they
think it makes them safer but ultimately
I think people will fight for it again
and I possum always makes the point that
you know revolutions are not quick that
I mean they take decades or more and so
why should the Arab Spring be an
exception like it's it's bad right now
and it doesn't seem hopeful but these
things don't take five years so I think
his legacy is that people saw that it's
really good for society to have a joker
who's holding power accountable and I
think he educated people on a lot of
things and these jokes to help them see
those things and my hope is that God
will inspire other people to do more
there one guy in the film the
cartoonists that they mentioned on deal
to me it was kind of the spirit of the
film because he's a young guy
very early in his career he was a writer
on the show and he still was doing a lot
of this stuff I mean he's trying to make
a show where he's kind of a Stephen
Colbert character and it's not easy and
I think you know hopefully wouldn't be a
harm to himself but he he's a political
political cartoonist and is very much
still vocals so there's still people
trying to do it right right and I really
I love how I can't remember if it's
right at the end but I know that at some
point near the end you have a sort of
call to action which i think is unusual
for a documentary and particularly a
film about a comedian so I was wondering
if you could talk about your thinking
behind that yeah absolutely
well the call to action is that each
person should find their own way to
start tickling giants so I mean a little
bit of what I was talking about before
but everyone can do a thing whatever
your thing is and for some people it's
more creative for some it's more
scientific I read something today that
made me think of something related to
this group which was
I saw something that Tammy Duckworth was
talking about legislation she introduced
for there to be places for women to
breastfeed in airports because you can't
likes it in the public toilet and very
easily do that and I remembered reading
something about MIT a few years ago I
had a hackathon to create I think it was
like the breast pump that doesn't suck
and it was an example of people using
their own specific talent to stop a
group of people in this case nursing
mothers from from having to not be able
to have an equal role in their society
and it's like a really interesting
example of people taking their thing and
and helping their skill set there was
another thing I saw last year where
there was a woman who makes font types
and she realized that Hebrew and Arabic
I forget which is which but I'm one if
you cover just the top half of the word
you can still read it and then the other
if you cover just the bottom half of the
word you can still read it so she made a
font that combines Hebrew and Arabic
because she was like if you can't even
like ever read the same information how
could you ever start a dialogue I
thought that was super cool like that's
a very specific skill set that she used
to have at least a starting point so the
call to action particularly giants is
for everyone to find their thing I think
it can apply in a lot of ways there's
the hard way is finding the thing that
you care about and then finding a way to
combine your talent with that thing
there's easier ways to do it like
signing up to vote and then voting
there's there's easier ways to stop an
abuse of power and those are important
to you and the call to action in my mind
would be to think about what your thing
would be and in the meantime because
that can be hard to do until you know
what your thing is help someone else
achieve their thing so if someone else
cares about an issue that you care about
and they have a way that they need help
support them while you find your own way
to help and you when we talked briefly
before you had mentioned that though
this film was made
prior to the 2016 election that watching
it now some people have said to you oh
you must have updated it because they
were seeing new things in the film and
I'm wondering so what in particular do
you think is standing out to people now
like on on watching it in a new moment
in this country yeah so it's been a
super weird thing where a bunch of times
people have worked on the film who've
seen it again this year including the
editor of the film like the last person
who ever touched the film saw the movie
a few months ago and asked me when I
changed it and I hadn't I didn't know
what he's talking about and then it was
like it just felt different like what
was different and I was like nothing you
are the last person to ever touch it and
I kind of had that experience when the
movie first came out and we were at a
festival it was the weekend after the
presidential election here and I watched
the movie and I'd seen the movie a
thousand times and I just felt different
and I the audience reactions for
different I think before people here
while watching it is a thing that
happens someplace else and now that
we're watching it as a thing that might
be happening here and a basically a what
what could happen if we don't try to
make sure that we don't let things and
freedoms slip away and there are so many
things in the movie that wouldn't even
have made sense before so we didn't put
them in like you know two and a half
years ago we're in the edit and people
didn't know the term fake news so we
didn't include it because I was a very
hotly debated thing there and do you
trust anyone in the media and do you
trust all the you know the government
had to stay around media but like bossom
was called fake news there's there's a
woman two weeks ago who in a story we
can't relate to it all here but a woman
accused someone of sexual harassment and
the they put her in jail saying it was
fake news so we didn't even know that
term and then this is what's going on
kind of in this story and then another
thing that was
something that we didn't include it all
in the film because it was just too
complicated we're like we'd have to
explain so much Friday and says here to
get it was the idea of paid protesters
and suggesting that someone wasn't
actually speaking out because they
believed in something they were only
speaking out because someone put them up
to it and that was just such a foreign
concept to the kind of young audience
that we were aiming for here that we're
like oh that's too much to get into we
won't explain it and then now of course
those are all really readily available
ideas for us and the movie is about a
guy who makes jokes about a president
and that president doesn't like it and
it stops him and I mean this last year
or so their president Trump tweeted
about alec baldwin and michelle wolf and
samantha bee and all these things that
are just inappropriate for a president
to vocalize and and of course all of the
many many comments about the press and
how they can't be trusted and they're
evil and all these things that are
dangerous i mean you know we saw this
week journalists are it's a it's a
dangerous job and to discredit them is
only trying to remove that that extra
lens on the people in power and and
bossom was trying to shed light on that
and I think when I was making the movie
I was very aware of the fact that I'm
not Egyptian and for me the movie is
about free speech and free expression
and it happens to end the backdrop of
the Arab Spring but I always probably
I'm not the perfect person to tell the
story of the Arab Spring I think I'm a
decent person to tell the story about
like using jokes to draw attention to
abuses of power so that's what the story
was for me and then now as an American
when I watch it I see it a lot more from
the experience of what's happening to my
country and I actually emailed with on
deal the political cartoonist shortly
after our election and I said what do
you do when your country isn't what you
thought it was and it's all changing and
how do you handle that and he wrote back
and he said well first you have to
recognize that your country didn't
change you just didn't realize it what
it wasn't for a lot of people in your
country they already had to deal with
these issues and you might have been
immune to it but you have to recognize
that and then you keep going and you you
know you try to stay motivated and stay
active well and speaking of the
president who weighs in on you know he
seems to have a very thin skin and
weighs in on comedy in a way that is
unusual for American politicians and
public figures as somebody who's in that
industry is it just really tempting to
try to bait I even try to get a reaction
I I don't think so I mean I don't think
it's like trying to I mean it's pathetic
when the president engages in a fight
like that so I don't think it's I don't
think the draw is to like be a troll and
bait somebody into it at all I think
it's I mean I think most people who make
satire would be very happy for him to
abstain from those criticisms I think
it's more like the challenge is how do
you make jokes about things when
everything's so absurd like there's a
big challenge in the last few years of
sitting in the room and pitching a story
and then being like well anyone know
that's a joke
like is that obvious or is that it's and
the news cycles so fast now that those
are more of the challenges I would say
but no I don't know I know it's too sad
when he does it so yeah yeah yeah well
and I I did want to ask you if we can
segue into this sort of late-night
comedy world I it is a world that's been
notoriously male-dominated and that's
changing to some degree and we can see
it changing but obviously the
demographics don't just flip on a dime
so I'm wondering if you've found
particular challenges as a woman working
in the industry or how that has been for
you
I think so I mentioned before one of the
things that was interesting to me when I
met Boston was that two of the people at
his show we're women and then when I got
there like if you see the movie I was
shocked at the vast majority of his
staff being female
there was still a division in terms of
the writers room which is where the big
division is here I think people always
talk about there not being women in
comedy and there's tons of women who
work in late night there's fewer on the
creative side so I was really important
tire research team was probably I know
maybe 90% women like it it was very
different there and and what my initial
interest was based on the bias that just
didn't exist I thought it was going to
be harder there to be a woman in late
night and what I found and the reason we
don't really go into it in the movie is
it was a total non-issue and it was just
my ignorance that made me think that it
might be an issue no one seemed to care
at all which was interesting to me since
it is such a big conversation here I
would I
I think it's a challenge that's getting
better but definitely still a challenge
I chose reflect who the people in charge
want to hire and some people have really
made I think Trevor Noah has made a big
effort to diversify his staff not just
gender but backgrounds race lots of
different ways and Hasan Minhaj has a
new show coming out and it seems like
they've really made an effort to
diversify their self and I I think it
reflects why you want different people
hosting because I think people tend to
want people who share their experience
writing and producing for them and
there's an assumption that that will be
someone who looks like you so the more
different people hosting the more
diverse those staffs will be I think
it's also about hiring more diverse
entry-level staffs because people tend
to it's not a problem that solves itself
quickly because shows in a way of
loyalty I think want to hire people who
they know and have seen do a good job
for them
and because for years they've done a
horrible job hiring a diverse
entry-level round of people then when
they give promotions the people who
they're promoting are mostly why more
male than female but it has in the time
I've been doing it changed a decent
amount like I when I first worked at The
Daily Show I was in the field department
for three years and then I switched to
what we called studio which was anything
in the studio so it was pitching ideas
for John or then Trevor at the desk or
any correspondent pitching an idea for
them at the green screen or at the desk
and then finding the video for those
things and the first year I was in
studio I would go to the two writers
meetings each day and that first year
there was a female writer who had left
and so there'd be 30 people in the room
and my self and the writers assistant
were the only women hmm that's weird
you know and I think it wasn't a show
they didn't want to talk about issues
relating to women women but the pitches
were less commonly coming from that and
it it became a joke like a running joke
that I would pitch these kind of dark
stories or but really they were just
pitching stories about women's issues I
think some people were a little less
comfortable doing so if I could pitch
something about campus sexual assault or
rape or abortion it would stand out more
just because there were fewer at the
time that dramatically changed and the
time I was there were more people
including the men were pitching those
kinds of stories so I guess I would say
it's improving and there's a very very
long way to go right right and I asked I
happen to be interested in I'm doing
some research right now on feminist
comedians in particular and and I'm
thinking of what I've done a thinking of
turning into a book actually on sort of
feminist comedians as cultural
battleground in some way isn't really
interested in the way that you have you
have more and more visible female
performers obviously and beside behind
the scenes which is great and that you
are getting these sort of new issues and
new concerns which are coming out
people are and just more likely to talk
about sexual assault or structural
inequalities and all sorts of things
like that but then at the same time you
have this very sort of like visible
backlash at the at the same time and the
sort of really kind of vitriolic
trolling which another theorist refers
to as gender trolling you know it's very
very much that that sort of trolling is
different the tenor of it is different
when it's aimed at women and people of
color and we see some of that even
coming from the president right and and
so any some of these little sort of
cultural controversies that flare up
around jokes or whatnot
aboot Samantha bees joke about Ivanka
Trump the Michaele Wolf's dinner all of
those things that you can really see
this sort of the culture wars play out
in real time over how you know the
language that's being used and what's
being mobilized there sorry I'm going
off on a tangent but I but I'm just
interested in what that feels like from
the inside right and from your
perspective yeah I think I mean it
sounds like an interesting book I in the
case of Michelle wolf in my mind there's
no question that the level of response
to her was very much connected to her
being a woman I think I watched her
speech and didn't see the backlash for
like another day and then I thought did
I space out during the speech but I
really questioned myself because I was
missed that part I miss that part yeah
and then I looked at the clip and I was
like oh it's intentionally being
distorted and her speech should have
only been noticed because it was really
funny and I mean she didn't do anything
there lots of guys haven't done in that
same room before her and she was funnier
than a lot of them so the fact that she
got called out for making fun of a woman
and all these things it just literally
didn't happen if you watched it in
context I it made no sense and I think
that was an example of the media there
were some people in the media who were
like well maybe she went too far and I
was like this is she was a comedian
invited to a comedy event
tell jokes and that's what she did and
then everyone should have been standing
up for her and and and most imporantly
she was funny like the number one
obligation is to be funny if you're
doing that so yeah I mean I think
there's fewer women so things stand out
more like a thing about Bassam is that
there was one of him so it was really
easy to be critical and to hurt the
infrastructure I think something that's
really great in our culture of satire is
there's a lot of people I mean you might
say like oversaturation but I think it's
a really good thing because there's
something for a lot of different
audiences and as a group there's so much
stronger because there's a bunch of them
it's harder to pinpoint or deconstruct
too much of what they're doing but
there's very few women and I think who
at least get a big microphone like
Samantha B Michelle wolf Sarah Silverman
Robin thede had something for season
there's people doing it and who have
done it but there's fewer and I think
they just get torn apart more over
things that a guy has and would say
again and it would kind of be no big
deal right yeah no one I'm interested
I'm and I I'm glad that there were
others of commentators who started
noting it as well but it was so
fascinating to me particularly even the
tweet that sort of started everything
around Michelle wolf was and I'm
paraphrasing it but it was something but
I and you know offended on Sarah
Sandra's behalf that I can't I couldn't
I was horrified at watching Sarah
Sanders a wife and mother being insulted
on national television and there was all
this language then around it around
essentially litigating you know being a
woman in public right and there was this
sort of like the good sort of motherly
figure versus the shrew essentially
right the community I mean there's
probably every woman in this room has
had it's not I don't think for a woman
weird to imagine this experience
happening like you know you're a little
kid in school and you see boys speaking
out of turn or different things and get
away with it and then
you know you're a little loud once and
you get in trouble or I think it's like
a cultural thing that's not in any way
exclusive to comedy that a woman might
make that joke and it offends people to
their core and a guy might and it it
would be totally forgettable
but yeah but you mentioned that you the
sort of perhaps saturation of late-night
and just that there's a lot of choices
right now which is great if you enjoy
satire right that there's there are
choices there's kind of a boom right in
particularly in sort of parody news
shows of different of different versions
and I know that you were involved in
Jordan Klepper show the opposition which
unfortunately was recently cancelled do
you think it's becoming harder for these
types of programs to distinguish
themselves and is there a sort of
challenge there I think the opposition
was a character show like Colbert type
of thing and I think that's really hard
and I you know in that example I think
even jokingly the audience it was on
after The Daily Show in the audience who
watches The Daily Show even jokingly
didn't necessarily want to see someone
saying these horrible things and that
was kind of a concern from the first
time we talked about the idea like I
don't know if people are gonna be up for
that
and I don't so I don't know I'm not a
fan of Alex Jones you don't want to
write and I think Jordan Klepper people
people knew Stephen Colbert already and
he was in character on The Daily Show
where Jordan Klepper was not that
character previously so there was a
question of just like oh wait is this
guy joking does he believe these things
you know it's a harder thing I think in
general I really like the fact that
there's lots of shows I mean you know
you probably are only gonna watch one or
two of those even if you're a fan of
these things it's not like you're
watching eight satire shows a week so
there's a thing that suits your needs
whatever that is but I mean like
everything I'm sure it's a trend and
then the I mean these shows have a
tendency
to be more liberal and usually when a
conservative is in power they're more
popular so you know who's to say in two
years will it be less popular I don't
know it's not like things get better all
over the place when when Obama won
people were like oh you guys aren't
gonna have a show anymore and it's like
there are plenty of things still going
on in this country to poke fun at around
the world so um you know but there's
probably a bit of a cycle to it right
now where people are frustrated and
there's a real hunger for some
therapeutic way to deal with it with
company sure and I know we need to open
up to the audience in just a second but
I so I guess just one last question is
to you do you have an eye to your next
project or are you giving it some time
um a little bit of both in theory I'm
giving myself time but I I find it hard
not to France from a little and try to
develop some things so I have a few
ideas for a scripted show and movie and
then I have an idea for kind of a
late-night style sa da ki show that
would be one episode sorry one topic per
episode kind of deep-dive john oliver
style but focusing on stories relating
to women and minorities so that's kind
of the one I've worked on the most
outlining what those episodes would look
like but for a little while I'm trying
to do some of these talks on campuses
and when I was doing the shows I I
couldn't really do a lot of these
because my schedule was crazier and now
I can do more of these and they're fun
for me so that basically I'm trying to
buy some time to figure out what I want
to do next
fair enough great should we open it up
to questions from the audience
okay I'm feel free to step up the first
person is always the bravest so you win
yeah I
we talked earlier but I'm Tania Ballard
Brown I'm a fellow with the Nieman
Foundation for journalism at Harvard and
in my regular non Jewish life
editor at NPR and the question I had was
were there things that you learned
watching how Yusef show was produced and
created or conversations that they had
or things that they did on that show
that you took back to the Daily Show or
that you even took to the Clipper show
that you hadn't thought about before or
that were new ways of sort of doing
things at that show they did a lot more
it was kind of a cross between an SNL
type show and Daily Show in the sense of
it was just much bigger like it was very
typical to have like a song and dance
number and um but like comedy but not
something we really did on the daily
show until like a little later in my
time being there later in John's room we
did kind of somewhere of those there was
a I forget now if this was before after
I started the film but I think it was
after there was forget even what it was
in response to but we had a gospel choir
come on and [ __ ] you
yeah the go-fuck-yourself choir that was
a piece I worked on and that was like
way more in line with something Boston
would do so I think more of what I took
back and and I actually remember on the
first trip writing an email to the staff
at home just being really struck by how
motivated they were by what we were
doing and kind of trying to not take for
granted both the impact it was having
and also the freedom we had in doing it
and that I mean daily show would have
like weirdos who would protest things
occasionally and but almost all
non-violence so it kind of appreciating
that it was a luxury to be able to do
comedy in that environment and that was
something I really took home and felt
very grateful for
do we have other questions squeak-squeak
so now having seen this from Egypt and
obviously worked on shows here what do
you see as the what kind of effect do
you see those type of shows having in a
political climate on a population is it
actually something more than
entertainment or and is that role
different where you have a truly
oppressive regime versus I want to be
oppressive regime I don't want to be
China I think there are a bunch of these
shows that have sprung up kind of all
over the world which is really cool some
much bigger than others and some not
necessarily in oppressive regimes but in
places where this exact type of thing
was happening I met a guy a few months
ago who was visiting and had seen the
movie who's doing a French type of thing
like this on their HBO equivalent and
it's a newer thing there I think to me
the impact is only depending on on what
the audience does with it so there are
many people who watch comedy segments
here and share them on social media and
that's great and that can make you feel
less alone or make you aware of
something but it doesn't really do
anything and the way I feel about comedy
is very much like the way I grew up
hearing about like religion and prayer
which was prayer doesn't change things
Pro changes people
people change things and I think the
same is true of comedy comedy doesn't
change things
comedy changes people people change
things so if and this could be in a
country where this is new or here if you
see something and it pisses you off and
makes you laugh you might be a drop more
likely to be open to at least talking
about it raising awareness and then
maybe even doing more but just watching
it there's nothing
externally it's just comforting to
yourself sharing it doesn't really do
anything it just lets your community
know you're a member of the group and
makes you wear it but it doesn't really
change a thing I think in the case of
possums experience what was interesting
is it inspired people to to do more and
to be open comedy is really cool because
like if I said something bad about a
politician you liked you'd probably turn
off right away but if I use a bunch of
video clips to prove a case that they
were being a hypocrite and they made a
joke about it you might actually at
least be open to watching it and that
was happening week after week for bossom
and and for a lot of these other shows
and and here too and I think that can
make a difference and one cool thing I
learned doing some of these talks is
there's a professor at Penn State and
Sophia McLennan who does research on a
lot of these things and she told me that
sometimes when you're making this stuff
you're not sure like you just screaming
into an echo chamber and apparently her
research has shown that people who just
watched the news all day and care about
current events aren't necessarily likely
to be active and in doing anything but
interestingly people who like to watch
satire are way more likely to actually
do something about it so the kind of
person who decides to turn into a show
at 11:30 to help them laugh about the
thing that's making them feel crazy is
more likely to actually get excited and
and do the thing to make a difference
and that was cool to hear from my
perspective because it's like you put a
lot of effort into this stuff and the
main goal really is just to make people
laugh but of course if you're working on
the show you personally probably have an
interest in making it change in these
things so so if you like satire pat
yourself on the back cause you're more
inclined to be
and if you don't mind if I add to that
too because I was gonna say that you
know because I write about satire as
well I sometimes get past for quotes and
whatnot when journalists are doing a
story about some thing that just
happened right and they have this
oftentimes not always but this
incredibly narrow way of talking about
the effects of satire which makes me so
annoyed because it's always asked like
do you think this is going to affect the
election is this going to
single-handedly like bring down
so-and-so you know and it's such a
strange way to measure efficacy because
it's like very little in human history
actually operates that way right we're
like one thing will suddenly change
everybody's not mind and like it'll
single-handedly bring down that wall
whatever right like that that's just not
how stuff happens but but what I'm
really interested in and in my work I
talk a lot about the way in which satire
there you can see the effects of satire
in the way that it can slowly shift the
conversation write it which is actually
a very large thing so just that the
terms that are used right it can
introduce new terms into the debate or
it can bring what what's otherwise a
sort of a niche issue that only like a
small public is talking about to the
larger public and just you know the
shifting that conversation in small ways
is small but as you said I mean I think
this is how people cultural change
happens slowly and it happens over
conversations that we're having with
each other over and over and over again
right and those are sort of slowly
shifting over time and you don't see the
effect until you're there right and also
in this idea of sharing clips with
people that you know we have this
expression where we say well it's just
preaching to the converted as if that's
the most waste of time thing that you
could do right but there's a reason that
a preacher preaches to the converted
every week which is that we need that
right we need that affirmation and we
need to feel like we belong to some sort
of community and that there are other
people around us who feel the same way
and we're not the only person who's like
am I the only person seeing this right
but like no we we have you see it - oh
my god we're not crazy right and there's
sort of strength in numbers and I think
you can't
you can't form a political movement
until you have that sense of like
community and shared purpose right so I
think all of those things know I think
that's true and I think but I mean I do
think sometimes like in embossing case I
think he was largely credited with
making people distrust their first
democratically elected president who was
then removed from power so I think the
people who hate him would say because
half the country is watching him each
week he had such a strong influence that
people didn't necessarily think long
term am I so I mean it's not to say that
a comedy show can't change things and
she changed people I I mean related I
want one of the coolest things for me
with the movie has been the bipartisan
nature of the audiences in the sense of
I hoped that Daily Show fans would like
it and that luckily was the case but I
didn't have any idea that it would do
really well with conservatives and
libertarians and all these other groups
and that was a big surprise that on the
way to one of our first screenings I I
got a call that someone working with Ted
Cruz wanted us to know that he was a fan
of the movie and I was like what that's
so I never would have expected that and
then as it went on Glenn Beck turned out
to be a big fan and had bossom on and
then the weirdest one for me that I kind
of had to figure out how to handle was I
was asked to screen the movie for
something with the the Koch family and
I'm I always thought I was moderate the
last few years I've learned I'm very
liberal but I not a fan and I wasn't
sure if I should do it my brother was
like you can't do this in the next room
they're going to be trying to dismantle
healthcare and I was like you're right
and then I was talking to my
brother-in-law and he was like no you
have to do it like you didn't make this
movie to only show it to people who
agree with you and I was like you're
right
so I I went
and it happened to be that we ultimately
did a few screenings with them but the
first screening was the weekend that the
Muslim ban was announced and so I
decided I was going to do it but I was
going to be very open about my opinions
and you know what I thought
and so in the Q&A I talked about the
fact that possum is a perfect example of
a Muslim immigrant coming to this
country because it wasn't safe for him
at home and that's who we're talking
about and we had a good conversation and
the next day the koch's
issued a statement condemning the Muslim
man and I have no way of knowing if it's
directly related or not I know some of
them were in the room but it made me
hopeful that sometimes it's really it's
so hard right now to stay calm about
anything going on but I do generally
believe cooler heads prevail and that it
I think like a lucky thing with this
movie for American audiences is that
most of us don't know much at all about
other countries or pay any attention so
when people watch the movie they don't
have a horse in the race and they can
just pay attention to their opinion and
I've learned that free speech is
something that both sides really care
about and they come at it for different
reasons for conservatives and
libertarians it's more about college
campuses and feeling like speech is
condemned on campuses for liberals it's
more about press and feeling like the
media is being condemned but they both
come to the conclusion that we have a
history of free expression and we need
to protect it and that makes me hopeful
that on some things there can at least
be a starting point sorry to give a
question so who are you my name is Julie
Fox and I'm a member of the community
and there's no other week where we're
more aware how dangerous journalism can
be and speaking up can be and I was
wondering as I was
listening to you if you could give us a
window into the creative room if there's
any discussion about should we do that
should we say that is that going too far
is there any degree of censorship is
there any degree of fear and has that
changed over time well yes I mean I
think it it might be the most dangerous
time in history to be a journalist not
even meaning this week but just the
numbers around the world of journalists
being injured or killed yes of course
there's a conversation frequently about
should we say it but not so much in
terms of self-censorship more along the
lines of there are things that are funny
in the room that you would never want to
say in front of a microphone because you
have a rapport with the people you're
sitting with and you understand the
context of a joke or different things
but it might be super offensive to say
it to someone who wasn't part of that
earlier conversation I think there's a
lot of times conversations about
anything happening to do with like kids
or someone's kid a public figure not
wanting to do that there's conversations
about a lot of times it comes out of the
idea that there's so many bad things
happening is this the one to go in on I
mean I can't count now the number of
times we're doing a show and a school
shooting happened and do you say
something at the top of the show do you
rewrite the open do you do it tomorrow
once you've processed it do you wait for
the next one because there's gonna be
another one and we have a piece we've
been working on that's not quite right
you know there are these other things
that you consider when we started the
opposition one of our test shows was
during like the weekend after the the
week after Charlottesville and it was
like one of the first shows we had
written and how do you make that funny
and what do you do with it especially
through the lens of a character who
would have some sympathies to these
people how do you do that in a way
that's
funny but I mean the fun cool thing is
like if you like doing this you on those
days you come in to the morning meeting
and everyone watches clips of whatever's
going on and everyone makes jokes any
jokes that people laugh at get written
in the notes and you start the meeting
with something that feels unthinkable
and an hour later there's usually at
least one thread that feels kind of
cathartic and then you work on that for
the rest of the day and that's cool and
sometimes and I think like the
responsibility you feel if you're
someone who loves satire is to go after
the hard stuff like those are my
favorite pieces are the ones where you
don't think there's any way you could
possibly do it in the morning and then
you find the way because those are
important and I think most of the other
stuff isn't really important that it's
entertaining it's really nice to have
but I mean more and more and I think now
under this president it's really
important to have this accountability
it's not just like a nice fun luxury to
have so I think that's more of the when
should we do it or I like I'm definitely
someone who thinks there's not a single
thing that you can't make a joke about
but there's tons of jokes that I don't
like or I think are stupid or offensive
or just not funny like I think if you're
funny wing in that particular joke you
can do it and you can find a way to make
it work and I mean like there isn't a
place in history where there wasn't they
were in a concentration camp or in
slavery or there was someone there who
was like cracking a joke to the Virgin
Nexen because that's the nature of
humans and and the worst something is
the more you need to laugh so it is a
balance of finding how to do it and when
to do it and feeling like it's the right
moment and the right joke I I'm an exile
Jazeera journalist as I told you earlier
I have so many questions but I was ask
you to this idea that you know over the
last few years that comedy and these
late-night shows are actually more
reliable than journalism you know
has that put an added kind of pressure
on and I think you have addressed some
of that but how do the right to see
themselves when this is the kind of
narrative that's being built
regarding them being more reliable right
and the second question it's right we
don't want the time because I'll forget
your first question I come back to your
second question okay stay there so I am
I I would say there's always these
studies that come out but say more young
people get their news from The Daily
Show than from the news and I never
believed it I think they might get their
TV news from The Daily Show but I think
there's a lot of ways to get news now
and it's a self-selected group that
wants to watch satire I mean you
couldn't watch The Daily Show every day
and understand it if you weren't getting
news in some other way so maybe it's
your Facebook feed or Twitter or
whatever but I think people are more
informed than the polls would indicate I
think that in the room your first
obligation is just to be funny and I
don't think you're starting the piece
going how can we get people to think
about this issue and do this thing I
think pieces would be kind of boring if
you approached it that way it's like
usually the way we approach it is what
is the story and what is our take and
then from that you you try to lay out
the truth and jokes about the truth but
I will say there were a bunch of times
like where I'd be looking up a story and
I'd find a clip or something really old
or interesting or weird and I would have
no idea why mainstream news hadn't
covered it and they're shown that same
clip like I wasn't using anything that
wasn't available to anyone else with the
budget and a lot of what we were using
was free stuff on the Internet I mean a
lot of times it would be from like
c-span dot-org or things like that that
anyone could find just sitting at home
on their computer so I do get why people
seem to trust some of these shows like
The Daily Show a little bit more because
I do think that there's a huge value
placed on getting it right and not to
say that there haven't been mistakes
made but they're few and far between
and I think that part of that is a
luxury of I mean even though now there
shows once a week and daily shows four
times a week you're coming on once a day
for 22 minutes Twitter changes it a
little bit but the goal isn't to be the
first one to comment on something it's
have a really good take and I think that
helps be right where there's like a lot
of journalism now I think there's a big
pressure to be first and that's not good
message you know you're like you it's
good to get breaking news but you have
to be correct and what you're reporting
and sometimes I think how many shows
have had a better track record I mean I
mean that's fine and that's fair but
like if you think about John Oliver's
show I mean that's like a kind of essay
that would be like the long-form okay
you know and so there's an investigative
aspect to that and it seems that the
comedy shows don't aren't confined to
the conventions of journalism but they
are doing journalism right somehow I
mean I guess I would say they're doing
satire and satire can be long formed but
yeah but then the the the point that
you've also mentioned yourself was that
it's about you know trying to get things
right but what happens when you get
things wrong so for example Trevor did a
stint sorry did a segment on Pakistan
right some weeks ago and he got a lot of
blowback because he compared Trump to
Americana and so how do you measure then
the success of that segment because it
was funny for some people I was he was
he getting pushback because he got
something factually incorrect or because
people didn't like the point he was
making because the the perception to
suggest that like in Iran Khan was oh is
this the new prime minister Pakistan is
the same as Donald Trump okay the idea
that these two characters could be the
same and using this very like very like
flimsy kind of comparisons that you know
like failing to like tropes about
Pakistan essentially he received a
blowback for those from those people who
understand the country so he kind of
liked that segment was wrong
in that way it was funny was in certain
aspects but it wasn't accurate as he
would be on a domestic issue or
something outside on South Africa or
Africa you know so like when you receive
that kind of blowback there was some
blowback is there like a discussion so I
can't speak to that one guy I'm not
there anymore and I don't I haven't seen
it I guess I would say knowing the
process I would guess that some people
who knew a lot about that issue worked
on that story and even though the staff
is in America and you know Trevor is now
here in his from South Africa I wouldn't
necessarily assume that it wouldn't be
people who don't have a lot of
familiarity with the region and I would
also guess that he stands by it
unless he's issued an apology or said
differently so I think that's
potentially more of a case of a
disagreement and in the point being made
versus a mistake I think when a mistake
is made they have recognized it and
apologized I so I don't know if that
happened in this case if not I wouldn't
assume that it they perceive it as a
mistake I think what there's pushback on
so many things so many pieces someone
doesn't like it you know obviously
there's two sides perceiving something
and one side being portrayed in a
segment so it's it's not infrequent at
all to get pushback on something larger
the pushback the more likely people in
the office would talk about it
but I I would say like there's genuine
desire to get it right and so I think
there's also a genuine reaction of if if
people were rallying around something
and saying it was incorrect or
inappropriate or offensive I think the
people who work at The Daily Show for
example would would really think about
it and then say something if they felt
like they should
Hey hello so I'm a student here at MIT
and I was just wondering where you go if
you want to laugh like I we've been
talking a lot about news and I'm
definitely pretty deprived of news like
if there's not a talk on campus I don't
hear about it that's cool yeah but like
if you want to laugh like whether it's
like current events related or just like
in general like to make yourself happy
where do you like what sort I don't
personally like to laugh but I go to MIT
lectures when I do but I you know I have
to say I having worked in late night for
15 years and watching the news all day
every day
I definitely feel burnt out and since
you know leaving this show this summer I
have tried to limit my news consumption
to stuff I can read until the Cavanagh
hearings I hadn't watched the news for
two months more than 10 minutes mostly I
was reading these so most of my viewing
has been for the purpose of
entertainment and and trying to lighten
myself in the mood but I I like to see
stand-up sometimes I there's a show an
improv show that I like a lot but I saw
a few weeks ago and I was like oh yeah
sometimes comedy really helps that you
know I was in a bad mood and then I saw
this show and it just made things a
little easier
I like live stuff a lot so I'll I'll
tend to do that I also I mean I have a
lot of funny friends so I'll hang out
and drunk around about stuff and my
husband is really funny
so we'll joke around about things but TV
shows and and live events I would say
are mostly but but honestly right now
less satire cuz I'm just a little burnt
out on all of it sometimes I'll watch it
on all over segments or Samantha bee
segments to kind of hear their
perspective on something and
occasionally I'll like seek out what do
they have to say about this particular
thing this week
but I've paid back on it a little bit
just because I'm I'm trying to not be
24/7 news consumption I'm even when it's
comedy
what do you do I don't know if I do
enough in like trying to laugh often
enough which is why I like so you got
the this series of events I don't know
like I find like journalists or like
people who can write well they tend to
be like funny and insightful yeah yeah
not enough so I'm trying to work so more
comedy stuff on campus is a good thing
thank you hi I'm Adam zan thanks for
coming tonight you talked about taking a
bit of a break and I'm guessing the
documentary process very lengthy and
producing the show for multiple years
can also be like thee have you thought
about some short form things you know
Funny or Die for instance that's really
like three hours ago I tweet about okay
yeah a friend of mine wrote a parody off
of my so-called life which for the
students here that was a TV show in the
90s that was my favorite show when I was
fifteen and so she's trying to get Funny
or Die to produce it and so I told her
if she did I'd be happy to direct it or
produce it so yes but I the stuff I'm
the most into tends to be like a little
bit longer form at least episodic to
feature but one thing I've been
interested in doing that I don't know
how yet but trying to combine my skill
set with some of the issues I care about
trying to do some funny videos about
serious issues so maybe working with
some gun control groups or women's
rights groups to
to try and help them come up with stuff
that they would like to draw some
attention to their issue so that's
really interesting to me it's not
something I've done too much of I've
done a few videos for nonprofits just
like pro bono things but they were
really comedy they were more just
straight help us tell our story types of
things so it's something I'm open to I
think right now what's kind of exciting
is there are a lot of things that seem
interesting and I'll throw much the wall
and see what sticks the short things are
fun because they don't take years I mean
this this has been when I was making the
movie I was still I was at The Daily
Show so from 8:30 in the morning until
7:30 at night I'd be at work and then
I'd go to the edit and then the year we
were doing the edit I had a very weird
lucky thing happen which was I mentioned
that when I was shooting we didn't want
any publicity so as soon as we were done
I needed to fundraise so I set up an
IndieGoGo campaign and sent it to
everyone I knew and some people shared
it with other people and Oh an
acquaintance of mine worked for Save the
Children and had just gone on a service
trip with some people and posted the
IndieGoGo page and sent it to this woman
and who was on the trip and she watched
the video and went about her day and her
husband sat down to check his email and
it turned out he was the CEO of
Technicolor a really big film company
and it was shortly after Charlie Hebdo
and there a French American company it
was their hundredth anniversary and they
were interested in doing something to
celebrate recognize their anniversary
and they liked the idea of supporting a
filmmaker trying to tell a story about
free speech in the Middle East which was
amazing and when they called to tell me
I totally thought it was a prank it was
actually the day after John Stewart
announced he was gonna leave the show so
in 24 hours I was like I'm gonna lose my
job I have this cool thing happening but
that changed the scope entirely of the
film so I thought it was just gonna be
me and an editor cutting in my apartment
it turned out I had 12 full-time
employees and a bunch of interns and it
became a by comparison a huge project so
though was amazing for that year I
didn't have a day off
we worked weekends and their days off
for Tuesday Wednesday so that I could go
to work during the week and go to the
Edit nights and weekends so I'm happy to
have a little more free time now and not
do two jobs at once and then potentially
some short stuff too chemical in ski I'm
over here with a staff over at MIT the
question was about like the use of
parity in media because when during the
Cavanaugh hearings there was a clip that
came out that mixed Cavanaugh's
testimony with a scene from pulp fiction
with Jules and I was and that was
hilarious but I had like another friend
on social media that uses a lot of
vulgarity and he'll spend time and
either Facebook or Twitter jail so funny
that like as we have acts as the social
media some it's like I think something's
funny I'll put it out there but like no
traction or anything but it's seeming
that like the more people who are
engaged with it in that process and
there's more discussion but it's like is
that kind of making everybody feel good
is it actually being a barb that may
like or barber or feather as the case
may be with someone to make them a
little more taken aback to say hmm I
don't know about that because I just
seems like with with politicians the way
they go they just go about their
business and don't really think they
like their wife long coated or something
so it's like as people put that
information out there when when you tell
like when's a good approach for doing
parody online I mean so the Cavanagh
example I thought it was super funny and
honestly first time I laughed that week
so I think that's an example of sort of
a release and feeling not alone I don't
think someone who thought Kevin I should
be on the Supreme Court was going to
watch that and have this
moment where they revile you ated things
because of the snakes the pulp fiction
clip but I think it had had a big value
actually I'm like that's kind of a
perfect example of a tiny one or
two-minute clip that I think a lot of
people found joy in at a time when they
were in pain so I I guess I don't know I
think it had an is a question sort of if
it if it has an effect I mean I think
you know if the question is is Twitter
self-indulgent like yeah definitely
that's what it is it's people thinking
that their innermost thoughts should be
documented every 15 minutes and you know
I literally can't think of a person I
know who I think should talk to the
world every 15 minutes anyone I've ever
met so I think by design it's it's not
something that necessarily you know is a
a must-have for society to exist but I
think that there's good things to come
out of it I mean like in the Arab Spring
Twitter was a huge means of
communication and finding like-minded
people and finding places to meet and
being safe and helping people for comedy
I think it's like one conversation that
does come up on shows is someone already
made that joke on Twitter oh they
already talked about that on Twitter I
think you get to a point where it's like
okay it doesn't really matter that we're
going to do the thing we think is good
and in the way we think is good and
Twitter will beat you to it every joke
has been made on Twitter within two
hours about a story that comes out
hopefully what's being added in a more
long-form thing is have more value like
relative
speaking jokes are easy but for people
who write jokes it's more this the take
that makes it interesting and important
that it's one of the reasons why I get
frustrated by the push to be so
responsive to the news cycle and comedy
shows because if a story broke right
before we came in here and we're writing
a show right now and we're probably
going to try to make at least one joke
at the table about that big story that
joke is a throwaway joke like it warms
you up it's kind of funny but it doesn't
mean anything if tomorrow we've digested
it and we spend a day and a half coming
up with our point of view and the one
thing that we think is really important
to say that actually might add value to
the conversation Twitter is almost
exclusively the first part where there's
like a release valve and it's funny and
that's valuable but like the snakes on a
plane guy sorry I keep saying that the
pulp fiction thing was the pulp fiction
clip was I don't think came out
immediately
I think I think it was a few days later
if I'm not mistaken I know if anyone
knows but like someone had a thought and
then they were like probably processing
and then decided to make this clip and
maybe in that case it just took a little
longer to physically do the work of it I
have no idea but I think that clip was
better because I didn't see it the day
of the hearing the day of the hearing I
probably wasn't in the mood to take that
in and I had had a minute and then I
watched it and I was like oh that's
exactly what I wanted and I didn't know
it so I think that the value adds are a
little different between social media
and TV
hi I'm Kenneth Cox I'm a student here
first of all thanks for coming it was a
really great presentation I really
enjoyed it so I'm going to go back to a
point you made earlier about I think it
was a study from Penn State which found
that which suggested that people who
view satire as opposed to regular news
more often are more politically
motivated so to me that suggests that
there is a very positive benefit of
satire maybe not something intrinsic to
the medium itself but at least something
something to get people motivated about
being politically active but do you
suppose there are also negative
consequences of satire what I have in
mind is people who watch jokes about
political figures they respect Trump
supporters for example who maybe watch
these SNL skits feel offended do you
think that there's even a slight chance
of that contributes to some of the
political polarization in this country I
definitely think it's possible I mean I
don't I don't know I I've wondered that
I mean after this election and some
other times where I've wondered does it
just divide people more I think in my
mind the way around that is to try to
hold whomever is in power accountable
for hypocrisy or abuses of power and and
not just do it selectively like in the
movie the same people who love bossom
hated him once he started making fun of
the person who they saw as the good guy
and that's really common like I've had
many times where someone I know who's a
Daily Show fan will be like oh he's very
good but he got it wrong this time and
you know and he he didn't research it he
got the facts wrong whatever and and
usually my feeling sometimes I'd be like
yeah I don't think we got that one right
usually my feeling was more like okay
you disagreed with his point of view I I
think I don't
it's a cause and effect that like I
don't think for example someone who's a
trump supporter Tunes in with the very
open mind and then gets offended and
then leaves feeling differently about it
not to say that it doesn't happen on
certain issues but I don't think in
general that's what's happening I think
it's more that people are choosing
things that they feel relates to them
but like I when I was in the field
department at the Daily Show I would try
to book pieces and to my pleasant
surprise very often conservatives would
be fans of the show and and in certain
ways where I would be like I don't think
we're as divided as it would seem like
there when the movie Brokeback Mountain
came out I was working on a piece about
gay rodeos and I had to book a
homophobic cowboy and I think I went
through three dozen Cowboys before I
found someone who was homophobic I
wanted to go on TV and brag about that
and it's very hard to actually find the
people in these segments who feel so
strongly that they want to announce to
the world that they believe these things
I think when you watch these shows at
home it's easy to think everyone's
ignorant and racist and whatever the
other side feels this way and I think in
my mind that's that's a negative of
these shows because you're only seeing
the ones that are strong enough to make
it to air but I mean I think it's a
reason why you shouldn't ever get all
your information from a single source
including with satire and as a viewer
you have a responsibility to kind of get
different points of view but yeah I
don't know I've wondered that myself
like if it further polarized as people
do you have any thoughts on that and
researcher well I think I saw some but I
I don't think I mean it hasn't been as
specific studies sort of done on because
people are selectively seeking out the
media that they want right and I think
people have preconceived ideas and were
just like I would never watch this thing
because they have this conception of it
already I think in general I mean I've
done a lot of work on irony and act
and ironic activist groups and you know
I talk about the way in which irony is
really good for attracting attention and
sort of creating you know and getting
and creating that feeling of community
for people who do already feel strongly
about something or or feel a little bit
about something and they're reminded
they're actually and they're made to
feel more about it right but I do talk
about the way that it's certainly not so
when you have a group like the
billionaires for Bush when Bush was
president that they're probably not
going to convince anyone on the hard
core other side who would likely feel
excluded from that joke right and and
feel somewhat offended by it but that's
not really what they're setting out to
do so so no it's not a bridge builder I
think would be the answer to that right
it's not a bridge builder but I think
the billionaires for Bush when they were
doing that that wasn't their aim it was
to draw attention to money and in
politics right and around this
particular candidate make sense I would
say like kind of my current theory about
all this stuff is even though I think
dialogue is important and good I'm
currently less interested in trying to
convince people I disagree with that I'm
right and I'm more interested in trying
to convince people that I agree with
that they should be active participants
and things so I mean like in the
election right there's a hundred million
people eligible to vote who don't I'm
Way more interested in being like you
should vote and here's why then I am at
convincing my uncle why he should vote
my way so I think maybe comedy could
work in that way too like not
necessarily speaking to someone who
thinks completely differently than you
do but convincing someone who agrees
with you that it's worth their time to
do something I am Greg PC and you talk
about satire and late-night as being
largely progressive and left to Center
are there examples of conservative
satire and humor and from the from the
right yeah
there's red eye on Fox which is hosted
by I think Tom shaloo
there's I think when backs channel had
tried to do it I don't think it
succeeded there have been lots of
attempts more humorless crowd I mean my
honest opinion on that is no I think I'm
there's funny conservatives and I can
think of some people I know who I think
are very funny people I think it's a
combination of things that I think there
are more liberals and entertainment so
you're gonna have more funny people to
choose from and obviously the more in
the crop the better I think that the
bigger thing is punching down is way
less funny than punching up and I don't
want to watch someone who's already been
victimized get made fun of and I think
that there is an association the more
conservative you are and the with going
after groups that it's gonna be way
harder to conceptualize a joke where an
audience is going to be on your side and
want to laugh at it and I think that's
the bigger challenge Thanks I will see
ya I don't know if at the time he was
like as conservative I don't remember
maybe it was so maybe that's an example
then yeah it was Randy it was yeah but
but I think the punching down thing is
huge and then there also is some
research coming out now a colleague of
mine has done on psychology and a
partisanship actually which does
indicate that liberals tend to be more
comfortable with shades of grey and
irony irony in general and so there is
sort of more there seems to be more of
an interest in certain forms of comedy
versus you know what what and it's by
and large right versus what
conservatives are attracted to so so
there's some of that as well that might
people playing into it yeah but but just
in general the use I mean satire relies
so much on irony
and just you know it an interest in
irony or it or in sort of even having
your own ideas questioned or sort of
made fun of that that is kind of par for
the course if you're doing political
satire hi my name is Jason when you are
filming a documentary about events that
are taking an extended period of time
like yours how do you know when you're
done
versus like putting it down for another
six months and just kind of seeing how
things but that is a great question and
it's maddening you don't and then I I
guess there's a few parts of it
one is you run out of money and then
you're done
one is you you investigate a lot of
different stories and you give yourself
options and then you choose which story
you want to tell I mean we had a few
hundred hours of footage so there's lots
of stories you can tell and you choose
which ones make the most sense for you
and then you also you try to guess what
the story is that you're gonna tell so I
mean I mentioned that at the beginning I
had a very different conception of what
what the story would be on my first
shoot I panicked and I was like I don't
know what the story is going to be I
don't know how I'm going to tell it and
and talked to some friends at home who
had done similar things to get advice
and then in this film the director of
photography this guy well who happened
to be visiting New York this week so I
just saw him he and I were talking and
he just was we were just having a random
conversation and he said well you know
what's gonna happen is Cece the head of
the military he's gonna run for
president and he's going to wind up
getting elected and then it's gonna be
like none of this ever happened and
they're gonna shut the show down I was
like okay yeah whatever and then that is
exactly what happened and in our
conversation as it it was planted a seed
and as little steps of that process
started to happen I was like huh maybe
we should keep going until
- until until and then it wound up being
sort of the full prediction so that gave
me a basic outline of where to go but a
big debate for basically the best advice
I got on this film was to ask yourself
two questions in the edit
who is your audience and what do you
want them to feel when the movies over
so in my case there were a lot of
different kinds of audiences that we
were trying to reach Western audience
middle eastern audience people who knew
things about the Arab Spring people who
didn't younger older who might not get
the same jokes and references so I
decided that the audience I wanted to
appeal to was a younger Western audience
and I wanted them to leave the movie
feeling frustrated but hopeful and
inspired to do something about it and so
anything that didn't fit those things
didn't go in or at least didn't have to
go in and and that helped us figure out
which stories to include and we were
still filming some things at the point
we're in the Edit because bossom was
coming to America and there were things
and we weren't sure if the movie should
end in Egypt like right with the show
getting canceled spoiler alert sorry and
if we were going to end there one of my
favorite scenes that we shot was
immediately after the show was cancelled
there was a rehearsal for song and dance
number that they were doing that week
where basically they were saying [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you it's a CC and so
all these people just found out that
they were out of a job and there's
things they believed in was done and
they decided to go up to the rehearsal
room anyway and practice the number and
energy was crazy and at the end of the
song this one young guy looks into the
camera and he's like we will not be
stopped we will not be stopped and the
dream will not die and it was this
really beautiful moment and I I loved it
and I wanted it in the movie and then
bossom had to leave Egypt and it felt
like a really important part of the
story to tell that he had to leave his
country and
why and the circumstances and that scene
of the the dancing felt like an N and we
tried a million different ways and we
couldn't figure out a good way to keep
that scene in and then have the story
continued for another ten minutes so we
decided to remove it because that's not
where the story ended that I wanted to
tell I wanted the story to include the
fact that he had to leave so actually my
question is kind of about that you have
hundreds of hours of footage you chose
to tell one story what about the rest of
the footage do you ever think of
remastering or letting someone remaster
it
name a price I'll give it I know that
the other footage I mean there's a
million other stories that could be told
and I mean an example of how it could
work is I mentioned this guy Maziar
Bahari who was a producer on this film
he initially there were a few people
interested in making this documentary
and he initially thought about directing
moving about possum and had done some
early filming of him and then I had a
bunch of this plate and couldn't do it
and I was interested in ultimately we
decided to work together and he gave me
the footage so it still found a home I
mean it it's possible that there could
be other stories that we would tell
there was we've released a bunch of
stuff online just as extras things that
we found interesting that we couldn't
include things that didn't necessarily
need further context to make sense a you
know it's hard because like you raw
footage isn't necessarily interesting to
watch you have to either make it a
really long clip for it to make sense or
spend time cutting it so I most of the
stuff we released were things that we
thought we wanted to use and didn't have
a place for it that could exist on their
own the rest of it lives in hard drives
and probably won't ever be seen you
never know I mean awesome is doing this
one-man show now and he mentioned maybe
wanting some of the footage there was a
in the movie there's a scene of him in
the operating room but there was some
other footage but I thought he might
want that I sent him this week you know
there it's possible that it could
find other lives but mostly the whole
point of the shoot is to give yourself
options for the Edit and you don't know
which stories you're going to tell or
which ones are going to develop into
anything something might seem
interesting and it doesn't really go
anywhere so you film it and then you
choose kind of which things meet the bar
of what you want to tell but seriously
if you want to buy it
thank you so much I just thank you for
having me this was definitely the first
time I've done the talk in front of
equations so that makes me feel smarter
by proximity and I would also just
mention if you are here obviously come
tomorrow to the screening if you know
other people who might like the movie
you can find it at tickling giants comm
or on iTunes or Amazon and more so I
just want to say if you start thinking
of ways that your ticularly giants in
your own lives I'd love to hear what
you're doing so if you feel like putting
it on social media just hash tag it with
tickling giants so I can follow along
with what you're doing thank you
[Applause]